[Music]
and good morning everyone we're here to
talk um about
education which broadens the mind or
it's certainly supposed to
but some now argue that university
education is doing the reverse so first
it was argued that the curriculum was
dominated by a white male elite that was
immune to criticism and now others
contend that there's a work agenda of
acceptable ideas which prevails and that
can't be challenged without risk to
careers open debate they argue is out of
the question
so should we insist on the goals of a
plural space in which no one view is
dominant and no group silences his or
her opponents
or is university inevitably a rite of
passage in which the received ideas are
instilled in the current generation
at root is debate and freedom to express
any opinion is it an essential part of a
vibrant culture or an illusory ideal
that's really a vehicle for privilege
and prejudice
well to discuss this uh contentious
topic
we have a splendid panel on my right
julie bindle who is a radical feminist
writer journalist and author she's also
the co-founder of the law reform group
justice for women which since 1991 has
helped women who've been sentenced for
killing their violent male partners
on my immediate left is loki who's a
uk-based rapper and political activist
he's written for the guardian of course
he's been interviewed by numerous media
outlets and his oxford union debate
speech has been watched half a million
times on my far left unusually peter
lilly who's a british conservative
politician
he's a member of the house of lords he
was a cabinet minister in the
governments of margaret thatcher and
john major and he's been a long-term
critic of the european union now the
first question that i'm going to ask
people to address and i'm going to begin
with you julie is education dependent on
the notion that all views should be
considered
well i'm not um a proponent of blanket
free speech i think for example
holocaust denial should be criminalized
um and i think that we all have our line
in the sand
so for me it's not about enabling for
example
a highly privileged
white male racist sexists to be able to
come up with any old dribble that they
wish
i think we should have
proper discussions about curriculum and
about the way that
white elite
men still
dominate
universities but now they present as
progressive as opposed to just being
proudly
right-wing or traditional
for me this is about class so when i go
to universities the times i'm allowed in
there of course
and do talks to students i notice that
there are barely any working-class
students anymore at all
so universities have now become
just
holding pens for the elite
where
the kind of discussion that you might
want to have in order to reach a
conclusion is not allowed
because
the young people that populate our
universities in the main not all but in
the main
are so
certain of their views
that what they want is
constant validation they want total
capitulation to their own views
and as they've often told me and other
colleagues
they don't want to be triggered
or traumatized
when we talk about things as mundane as
rape
domestic violence and who is responsible
femicide and for example
that the women that populate the sex
industry
that they will insist on referring to as
sex work
while still claiming to be on the left
and to be progressive
when what we have
is evidence
that those women and girls in the main
that populate the global sex trade are
the most disenfranchised imaginable
so
i find that there is a
resistance
to ideas that challenge not only their
orthodoxies but also their innate sense
of entitlement and privilege and until
we have a proper mix in our education
system in our higher education system
class wise
in particular i think right now then
this isn't going to change
thank you
um okay i'm going to go straight on and
just ask you to address the same
question so i would like to start by
quoting someone who you know if anyone
saw the debate that i had with slavo
zizek you would see that i don't agree
with him on a whole lot however he put
it this way the most dangerous form of
non-freedom is the non-freedom which is
not perceived as such now it's my
conviction that we have a carefully
cultivated hierarchy of political
subjectivity in this country and that
that cultivation has taken place
with the complicity of
a member of this panel i will explain
how
if i were to tell you if i were to tell
you that when the national union of
students came up with the no platform
policy it was to stop speakers from
apartheid south africa coming and saying
what they wanted at that very time the
conservative government were cooperating
with the apartheid government despite
the fact that boss agents from apartheid
south africa placed bombs at three
locations in london targeting
anti-apartheid campaigners so when the
nus came out with this no platform
policy what do you think happened to the
nus well they were infiltrated by a spy
cop who goes by the name of peter
francis so the question has to be very
clear here who have been the main agents
and forces of
unfreedom in this country and cultivated
that lack of political subjectivity
especially when it comes to the
education sector what we're talking
about is a marriage
between the state and corporate
interests to blacklist and censor people
that speak against certain things within
the workplace you're talking about 3 000
construction workers who were
blacklisted by an organization that had
direct cooperation with special branch
and in case you're wondering how far up
the train this went norman tebbit who
was employment minister at the time in
the thatcher government said he was
being briefed on where trade union
leaders went on holiday so it's not
something that others on this panel had
no relation to at all then we talk about
prevent the equalities act in 2010
clearly says that you in the public
sector have no right to discriminate
against somebody for their religious or
political views what prevent actually
explicitly expects from people is them
to
carefully surveil muslim students for
things like signs of depression going
through changes in their life students
who speak more than usual students who
speak less than usual the youngest child
referred to the channel program is three
years old okay you are talking about
prevent opening up the space for muslim
children to be questioned by police
without the foreknowledge of their
parents that is the kind of society that
we have today and it has been formed
very carefully over many years so what
i'm saying just to finish is we also
have a government that is banning
anti-capitalist texts in schools this is
not a free society and it is absolutely
clear to say that in this carefully
cultivated space of uh of the hierarchy
of political subjectivity that some
forms of censorship seem to be more
visible and louder than others
thank you
peter
peter you're looking rather thoughtful
um
and could i invite you to address the
opening question about which just to
remind everyone it was whether all views
should be considered in education well
they should
even low keys um though i hadn't
realized i was guilty of all these
things until i heard it from him or
indeed that i had any involvement in any
of that but now i
was went to a school where he had to
specialize at a age of 12 i specialize
in science and continue to do that
through until i graduated in science so
i
i've only experienced i subsequently
didn't
crash course in economics but primarily
my educational experience is of teaching
of science
and in science every view does have to
be considered so the answering question
is yes
and any view can be challenged and any
alternative view can be put forward and
that can be challenged the test always
is the facts professor feinman great
physicist the last century said it
doesn't matter who invented a theory how
elegant that theory is
and he didn't add but one could add it
didn't matter whether the inventor of
that theory was a jew or a muslim a
conservative or labor what matters
is do observation do a predictions based
on that theory conform with the facts
if they don't the theory is wrong
it's as simple as that
now
teaching the humanities is different
different i grant you it's not as simple
as that but ultimately the test should
be facts it's not the authority of
person who
puts forward a thesis not even where
they're a nice person
einstein was pretty deplorable and
patriarchal and whatnot towards his wife
and women in his life
but that doesn't mean that the theory of
relativity is wrong that is tested by
the facts whatever we say should be
tested against the facts what loki says
should be tested against the facts if he
thinks that i was uh briefed in some way
about all these things um well
you were fighting the government that
did that i mean i don't know
i wasn't with the people there's no one
interrupted no no it's fair enough it is
a fact i was part of the government
which had deadly allegedly did things
but you allegedly not allegedly the spy
cops inquiry has laid it out for
everyone
allegedly it doesn't mean it's false it
means it's alleged i haven't seen that
evidence but i'm prepared to accept it
if i see the evidence i'm interested in
objective fact
i'm not interested in guilt by
association which seems to be your
prerequisite
so i rest my case
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas
you